[Music]
oh
there they are ladies and gentlemen the
bride and groom to be
emily and marcus
what the hell is that you son of a [ __ ]
you said we were best friends
what are you two doing here
excuse me this is a private event oh
it's cool we know the
room we met these two animals down in
mexico
why does the salt not taste salty oh
because it's cocaine what
i don't do drugs even on vacation
okay look we just got a container this
only happened because you said see you
later i said it without meaning it like
any decent person would
and somehow he's charming my dad hope
you're comfortable and enforce them once
there's at least one girl involved
everywhere they go chaos happens
this weekend is all about you well i
like the sound of that
we do too jesus good evening everyone
what is he doing
marcus and i crossed paths in mexico get
to know each other
intimately this is the best wedding i've
ever been to
put that bottle on your head babe he's
not serious we've been drinking it
count it you hit the bottle this time
what
[Music]
foreign
[Music]